hey 42 here conspiracy theorists are
often mocked and called tinfoil hat
wearing blue knees but whatever people
may say they have gotten the occasional
thing correct and sometimes the truth is
even scarier than speculations and
theories these are the terrifying
conspiracy theories that turned out to
be true we start with the conspiracy of
the MK ULTRA project the theory goes
that between 1950 and 1973 the CIA
carried out top-secret and disturbing
mind-control experiments on US citizens
unfortunately the theories turned out to
be very true in 1995
President Clinton actually issued a
formal apology on behalf of the US
government for the atrocities that they
committed the experiments carried out as
part of the MKULTRA project were highly
illegal all of the test subjects were
unwilling and the experiments involved
drugs electronics hypnosis sensory
deprivation z' verbal and sexual abuse
and torture in order to distance two
projects from the US government the CIA
subcontracted the work to 80 different
institutions including universities
hospitals and prisons
20,000 classified MKULTRA documents were
uncovered to the public in 1977 under a
Freedom of Information Act which
confirmed people's suspicions however
the director of the CIA Richard Helms
had most of the more damning MK ULTRA
files destroyed in 1973 so much of what
happened during the experiments
still unknown to this day next up is the
great diamond conspiracy during the late
1870s when huge diamond mines were
opened in South Africa it was suspected
that the diamond supply was actually far
greater than advertised and that the
price of diamonds had been artificially
inflated conspiracy theorists believe
that diamonds were actually worthless
well they couldn't be closer to the
truth until the 19th century diamonds
were only found in very small quantities
in riverbeds in India and the jungles of
Brazil however in 1870 huge diamond
mines were found in South Africa and
diamonds were soon being mined by the
truckload very soon the market was
flooded with an excessive amount of
diamonds the British investors who
funded the diamond mines soon realized
that the prices of diamonds rested
solely on the fact that they were so
rare if too many diamonds came into the
market their prices would plummet
diamonds would no longer be a precious
stone and their investment will be worth
absolutely nothing so what did they do
the investors realized that they had to
restrict the supply of diamonds to keep
the prices high
so in 1888 their handful of British
diamond mine investors banded together
into a single entity to form a cartel
called the Beers consolidated mines in
one fell swoop they had completely
monopolized the diamond market worldwide
the global selling price of diamonds was
now completely under their control the
De Beers Corporation achieves this by
stockpiling massive quantities of
diamonds in London warehouses and only
releasing a tiny amount into the market
each year to create an aloof
of scarcity but the beer soon realized
that only wealthy individuals were
actually buying their diamonds because
the prices were so hot so they needed a
way to encourage the working and middle
classes to buy diamonds so in 1938 they
came up with one of the greatest scams
of the modern day they invented the
diamond engagement ring De Beers
utilized a newly emerging medium of
motion pictures to plant the idea in the
heads of young men worldwide that the
only stone acceptable for an engagement
ring was a diamond
they paid Hollywood movie studios to
include scenes within their movies of
young men proposing to their loved ones
with a diamond engagement ring they also
launched a massive advertising campaign
with the slogan a diamond is forever the
campaign was an enormous success before
their campaign only ten percent of
engagement rings sold worldwide had
diamonds on them after the campaign
eighty percent had diamonds in a short
few years that the Beers company had
artificially inflated the global price
of diamonds and brainwashed the entire
world into thinking that these worthless
hunks of carbon are the only way to
propose to a woman to this day their
mass manipulation is still deeply rooted
in society the gulf of tonkin incident
was a major event in 1964 that was one
of the biggest contributing factors to
the start of the Vietnam War
however conspiracy theorists say that
the event never actually happened
the story goes that the u.s. destroyer
ship USS Maddox engaged free North
Vietnamese Navy torpedo boats in
the gulf of tonkin near vietnam has part
of the US intelligence patrol the
Murdochs fire done incredible 300 shells
that much is true however in 2005 a
study by the NSA revealed that there
weren't actually any Vietnamese naval
vessels present during the incident
whatsoever USS Maddox was firing at
absolutely nothing in 1965 President
Johnson actually said for all I know
our Navy was shooting at whales out
there next up is the conspiracy theory
that between 1932 and 1972 the US Public
Health Service were deliberately not
treating syphilis patients as part of a
clinical study to see what would happen
to syphilis patients if left untreated
unfortunately this turned out to be very
true 399 rural african-american men were
chosen by the US Public Health Service
who were suffering from syphilis the
Health Service never even informed these
men that they had a sexually transmitted
disease and they never offered them
treatment of any kind
despite the treatment for syphilis being
widely available the victims were simply
told that they had bad blood and their
symptoms were inevitable by the early
1970s
128 of the 399 men had died of syphilis
40 of their wives had also contracted
the disease and 19 of their children had
been born with congenital syphilis next
up is the theory that the Joint Chiefs
of Staff of the US military created
plans to fake our
of terrorism against US citizens on US
soil in a Cuban false flag attack to
persuade the American public to support
the war against Cuba it's completely
true and the official documents can now
be found online the plan which was drawn
up by the US military involved shooting
down innocent Americans on the streets
planes full of innocent people being
hijacked and shot down and over
extremely violent bouts of terrorism
taking place against the American public
in Washington DC Miami and elsewhere
across the US the plan was approved and
ready to go into action but thankfully
President Kennedy rejected it perhaps
one of the most well believed conspiracy
theories is that your own government is
spying on you we've all had that
paranoid feeling at some point in our
lives that someone somewhere is watching
us maybe it was George Orwell's 1984
that started it all off or just a
general distrust of the government but
whatever starts at the theories the
scary truth is your government is
watching you and it's not just in
America that it's happening in recent
years there have also been disturbing
reports of other countries spying on
their own citizens such as France
Germany China Russia Syria New Zealand
Canada and the United Kingdom of course
the most well-known of these spying
scandals was when former NSA employee
Edward Snowden released sensitive
government information revealing the
frightening extent of the NSA spying
activities on American citizens under
its surveillance program
code names prison thanks to these
revelations we now know that the scope
of the NSA's eavesdropping is even
larger than what conspiracy theorists
originally believed but of course all
the spying is necessary to protect us
from the likes of terrorists is it not
well not exactly a report by The
Washington Post found that ninety
percent of the sensitive data being
collected by the NSA surveillance
programs is from Internet users with
absolutely no connection to terrorist
activities making their spying
activities downright illegal for a long
time it's been theorized that
professional wrestling is fake and the
outcomes of the matches are determined
beforehand it's always been a popular
theory until recently when it was
confirmed to be true in 2013 a
mysterious Reddit user called dolphin's
19:25 who claims he has a contact inside
the World Wrestling Entertainment
Company started posting the results of
pay-per-view wrestling matches online
before they actually took place he
posted the results of 38 matches all of
which he got correct which proved once
and for all that Pro Wrestling weld at
least in the case of WWE matches are as
many suspected set up between 1920 and
1933 in the US was the alcohol
prohibition for a whole 13 years
alcoholic beverages in any form were
banned as you would expect this proved
very hard to enforce a lot of people
were secretly making their own alcohol
in their homes the FBI were finding it
increasingly more difficult to stop
people drinking
then suddenly people started dying from
drinking alcoholic beverages many
theories popped up that claims that the
FBI was intentionally poisoning liquor
to deter people from drinking it it's
frightening to believe books the Phebe's
were absolutely correct
the FBI's idea was that adding
potentially fatal impurities to liquor
it would demonize alcohol in the eyes of
the general public and stop people from
wanting to drink it of course they
didn't tell the public about their
nefarious plan they let the consequences
of the poisoned liquors do all the
talking for them the FBI added
substances such as kerosene chloroform
and acetone to bottles of liquor and
people started mysteriously dying of
what many believes were simply alcohol
poisoning it's long been believed by
conspiracy theorists the world over that
the world is run by a group of rich men
in powerful positions and that they meet
up every year to discuss secret plans
one such theory is that the world's
elite meet up once a year in the middle
of the woods and worship a giant owl
effigy well turns out it's true it's
called the Bohemian Grove it's a 2700
acre campground located in the woods of
Monte Rio California once a year
Bohemian Grove is host to a two-week
event involving some of the most
powerful men in the world during the
event they get drunk put on strange
plays in the woods and burn an effigy in
front of a giant owl statue however
little is known about the event and what
exactly is discussed by the rich and
powerful is kept top secret women aren't
allowed to attend famous Bohemian Grove
murrs have included Dick Cheney both
George Bush's Ronald Reagan Richard
Nixon John Major David Rockefeller
former CIA director William Casey Thomas
J Watson and many more unfine aliy
conspiracy theorists believed that the
CIA invented a heart attack good that
can be used to assassinate people
without a trace
turns out this is terrifyingly true the
weapon doors exist it was developed in
the late 1960s the gun was designed to
be completely untraceable
it fires a tiny bullet about three
millimeters wide that is made entirely
of ice this ice bullet has a lethal
shellfish toxin frozen inside it upon
entering the target the bullet would
leave only a tiny red dot on the skin
and the bullet itself would quickly melt
leaving no trace at all the shellfish
toxin causes a heart attack regardless
of the targets physical fitness levels
the toxin itself denatures quickly
meaning an autopsy is unlikely to find
any traces of it it is a perfectly
untraceable James Bond style weapon
however its existence was confirmed in
1975 when Senator Frank church was
forced to reveal the gun to a
subcommittee whom were investigating the
CIA's illegal activities because
assassinating someone on the streets who
doesn't pose a significant threat to the
state is illegal even for the CIA even
though its existence is now undeniable
theorists believe it is still being used
by the CIA to this day
Andrew Breitbart may very well have been
a victim he was a media
mogul who published derogatory stories
about Barack Obama he promised that he
would shortly publish proof that Barack
Obama's presidency was illegitimate what
he never got to do so because shortly
afterwards on the 1st of March 2012 he
suspiciously collapsed dead from a heart
attack whilst walking in a Los Angeles
neighborhood despite being of relatively
good health another possible victim of
the heart attack gone was Mark Pittman a
financial journalist who sued the
American Federal Reserve for mishandling
taxpayers money however before the case
could come to a conclusion Pittman died
of a heart attack in very similar
circumstances as Andrew Breitbart
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2
[Music]